[Applaus]
er geht zwar offiziell erst morgen zu
Ende aber wir können ja heute schon mal
fragen was hat der 27 Klimagipfel in
Ägypten gebracht unterm Strich tja in
Sachen Emissionen runterfahren leider
sehr wenig Hoffnung ist so das 1,5 Grad
Ziel ist nur noch technisch zu erreichen
was du vielleicht wie können wir knicken
der Planet steuert mit Vollgas zu auf
irgendwas zwischen 2,5 und 3 Grad sieht
also insgesamt nicht richtig doll aus
für unsere Enkel zumal ja fossile
Energien
die Sendung wird es immer geben ja
zumal ja fossile Energien dank Putin
einen Comeback feiern und so kleben sich
die Aktivisten der letzten Generation
weiter auf Straßenfest oder sie gehen
sogar bis zum Äußersten also zu Markus
Lanz sie sitzen hier mit 20 sie müssten
optimistisch sein sie müssten zutrauen
haben in die Fähigkeiten von Menschen
was ist das für ein Menschenbild unsere
ganze Menschheitsgeschichte hindurch ist
eine Geschichte der Anpassung sie
müssten zutrauen haben in die Fähigkeit
zur Anpassung dass Menschen sich
anpassen können natürlich ist das so uns
als Spezies hat erfolgreich gemacht dass
wir uns angepasst haben immer wieder
ich nerv sie gerade ja
so
man sieht es richtig
in diesem Moment wünscht sie sich dass
die Erde doch ein bisschen schneller
untergeht
einfach damit die Sendung vorbei ist und
wissen Sie was beide haben recht beide
wir müssen die Emissionen runter denken
und uns besser anpassen an die Welt im
Klimawandel und zum Beispiel endlich
Kiemen wachsen lassen
falls Plan A also Klimaschutz nicht so
klappt Deutschland versagt
bedauerlicherweise bei A und B zum
Beispiel in Sachen Vorbereitung auf
immer mehr Starkregen viel zu große
Flächen sind hier komplett versiegelt
wie soll das Wasser da abfließen in
Dänemark zum Beispiel ist man deutlich
weiter damit die Kopenhagener
Kanalisation nicht überläuft wird bei
Starkregen das Wasser hier
zwischengespeichert aber auch an der
Oberfläche tut sich was die Kapazität
die wir hier in die Straßen einbauen
basiert auf einer hydrologischen
Berechnung die zeigt wie viel Regen in
diesen Straßen bei einem bestimmten
Starkregenereignis fallen wird
was vorher was berechnen was für Spießer
diese Dänen oder echte Männer lassen
sich vom Unwetter überraschen und dann
sind da ja auch noch diese ständigen
Hitze Sommer die wir uns scheinbar
gewöhnen müssen in Städten ist es noch
mal bis zu 10 Grad heißer als auf dem
Land weil Betonwüsten Wärme speichern
und während es anderswo Kühlkammern zum
Schutz der Bevölkerung gibt können sich
deutsche Rentner höchstens bei Tönnies
Abkühlen sich an die Schweinehälfte
kuscheln
es gibt so viel zu tun bei uns wir
brauchen ganz schnell mehr Grün in den
Städten auf neben und unter den Häusern
allein das kühlt die Temperaturen schon
mal runter das Land muss größer denken
ich sag nur stuttgart 21 wird ihn nie
fertig der Quatsch können wir doch auch
als Regenrückhaltebecken benutzen genau
wie die Stadien wo eh keiner hingeht
hier Hoffenheim oder die Arena in
Leverkusen der perfekte Wasserspeicher
werden und wo wir gerade dabei sind es
gibt ganze Städte die keiner braucht
Recklinghausen zum
Vorschlag evakuieren und aufforsten
unser Motto Regenwald Stadt
Recklinghausen
ja bitte
sofort bevor sie sich aufregen das geht
jetzt gar nicht gegen Recklinghausen wir
brauchen einfach irgendeine hässliche
Stadt mit R das ist alles
und wo wir gerade bei der Anpassung an
den Klimawandel sind lasst uns bitte
auch über Katastrophenschutz in
Deutschland reden auch da ist noch sehr
viel heiße Luft nach oben am 8 dezember
ist bundesweiter warntag und hoffentlich
müssen wir beten geht der nicht so in
die Hose wie der letzte wissen nur noch
da haben nicht mal die Sirenen
funktioniert aber wir arbeiten dran wir
arbeiten dran Berlin als Beispiel wir
bis Jahresende 400 neue Sirenen auf die
Dächer Düben stand heute sind es 28
ja klar der muss jedes Mal der
Praktikant den Baumarkt eine Sirene
kaufen die Leiter holen in der Zeit hast
du locker einen neuen Flughafen gebaut
so weiß man wie es geht hier jeden
Samstag in Grimma
[Musik]
hier spricht Edgar Wallace
ich arbeite bei der Stadtverwaltung
bitte helfen sie mir ja
oldschool Sirene ist eine super Sache
Sirenen haben wir leider genau wie
unsere Bunker jahrelang abgebaut jetzt
müssen wir da wieder investieren und
wenn sie zu Hause sich jetzt fragen
warum haben wir eigentlich das BKK das
Bundesamt für Katastrophenschutz in Bonn
obwohl am Ende auch da wieder die Länder
zuständig sind zeige ich Ihnen mal wie
das ganze bei uns organisiert ist
ja was ich habe gesagt ich zeige Ihnen
das nicht erkläre ihnen das kann ich gar
nicht das Ding hat 16 Pfeile ja genau
dieses wirr war was Sie hier sehen hat
sich letztes Jahr bittergerecht im
atatal wo übrigens hauptsächlich
freiwillige und ehrenamtliche im Einsatz
waren was auch nicht nur ein gutes
Zeichen ist letzten Sommer hatten wir
auch noch nicht das cell broadcast
Wahnsystem jedes Handy im Krisengebiet
kriegt dann eine Warnung plus
akustisches Signal selbst wenn das
Telefon stumm geschaltet ist Frage warum
um Himmels willen kriegen wir das erst
jetzt die Technik gibt seit dem 08
Jahren
ja ich fürchte bis wir endlich
Katastrophen ready sind bleibt uns
Bürger nur die eine Sache es selber in
die Hand nehmen es wird zum Beispiel
empfohlen immer eine angeknipste Lampe
gut sichtbar in der Nähe zu haben und
diese niemals aus den Augen zu lassen
geht die Lampe plötzlich aus sind sie
möglicherweise ob eine Stromausfall im
Hochsommer im Hochsommer ist es ratsam
stets ein Hund in ihrem Pkw
aufzubewahren hört das Tier auf zu
bellen ist es draußen viel zu heiß
bleiben Sie unbedingt in ihrer
klimatisierten Wohnung bei jedem
katastrophenverdacht bitte rufen Sie
umgehend die Service-Hotline des BKK an
geht keiner ran heißt das alle sind
abgehauen und das sollten Sie jetzt auch
tun aber bitte vorher noch schnell ihre
Nachbarn waren denn die Sirenen sind
kaputt
[Musik]
sehr gut gemacht ja
keiner so und jetzt zum guten Schluss
noch schnell eine neue Folge unserer
beliebten Serie Hubertus Heil macht
einen Fehler und stellt Kindern eine
Frage
ich bin Arbeitsminister könnt ihr euch
vorstellen was man da den ganzen Tag
macht
[Applaus]
so Aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute-show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen